hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
Happy Thanksgiving everybody I'm joined
by Rachael Ray gobble gobble oh she's a
busy woman he can catch on the Rachael
Ray Show she has her magazine every day
with Rachel welcome to the show thank
you how are you a spicy food I have high
expectations cuz I saw you chugging hot
sauce with Jake small I don't know a
couple ah I think I'm pretty good with
spicy food I am however very particular
about wings you have a whole wing rant I
hear I have a wing ranch first of all I
only buy drumettes I don't like this
part of the wing I use this part of a
wing if I butcher the chicken myself or
stock along with the next what um so I'm
pretty picky about the wings
yeah yeah you don't just send an intern
over to Buffalo oh yeah I'm very picky I
will have a wing with you just to say I
did but I don't mind you bro I'm on a
roll gangster I brought in a cup of
spoons and I'm gonna try and do the line
I'll ribs TENS name is Maine latinum I'm
excited to see how this goes are you
ready to have done this yeah your
revolutionising the game really making
the grade
this Kara stone is sriracha you sauce
the winger sauce my own wing Rachael Ray
sauce is Rachael Ray no sauce in there
like you could do that whole line I'm
not gonna be impressed with any of it
I'm gonna be having way more sauce than
you ready all right okay delicious
you're the queen of Thanksgiving and you
keep it real that's why we had to have
you on the Thanksgiving special because
people who know Thanksgiving know that
Thanksgiving has the potential to fly
off the rails at any second so I want to
give you some common Thanksgiving
conundrums and you just tell me how
you'd handle them with your Thanksgiving
wisdoms okay so I'm an idiot I need to
bring a side dish but I can't cook it
all can you give me something with
layers something that will impress
people but it's kind of idiot proof I
think soups actually the easiest way to
go you can roast a pumpkin you know and
puree it with some stock and you made
soup but if you don't cook why don't you
just bring the booze what's the best
alternative way to cook a turkey smoking
it grilling it deep-frying it it's gonna
sound like I'd make it a joke but I'm
not um I also think spatchcocking a
turkey is is brilliant all that means is
removing the backbone of any poultry
it'll cook much more evenly and it just
allows you to sleep a whole lot later in
the day what about the annual turkey
bowl is it all giggles and high-fives
are you out for blood I don't have an
annual turkey bowl I'm the ones cooking
all day
Boone coming out spoon coming out Oh
doing that little daddy-doo on your wing
lightweight Martha Stewart and Snoop
Dogg they have a new cooking show that
makes me think about non-traditional
kitchen duo's and you've worked with a
lot of oddballs over the years there's
someone outside of the cooking world
that you ever thought you know what
would be fun to do a show with that
person I really wanted to have on action
but we just did a huge Action Bronson
fan you know people ask you all the time
what your favorite meal is there's no
such thing and cooks will eat anything
like literally mm-hmm for us what makes
us happy is to make people we love happy
with what we prepare so anybody that I
respect and admire I'd love to have in
the kitchen cuz I want to try and please
them and
Abbey I think you've organized these
correctly so it's like mildest two
hottest that's how it works huh it's by
the Scoville scale so we're going by the
knowledge yeah sure
outside of that so you want proper we
kind of made this into a little bit of
an orchestra so maybe we're kind of
feeling ourselves and maybe we're like
we're too self referential here but like
this is actually a an attack that we've
created sort of uh Lagos so this is a
little more complication yeah it should
be like proprietary really it's a whole
algorithm here I see you're gonna have
to bump up how much you're having cuz
look I'm taking okay a teaspoon of all
this stuff and you're taking one little
dot it's not a dot this has been tossed
in the bowl there is full coverage all
right but Rachel whatever I don't back
down if you want to keep up in the night
with you Oh see I thought that was
lovely
that should be hotter cuz it's habanero
the balance in that one is beautiful
this is the first time that we've ever
met but you're no stranger to first we
feast do you remember back in the day
when we reviewed your dog food recipes
with a real actual dog yet Seamus and
Oscar on the show do you remember that
various and you know I've eaten probably
more of my dog food at cat food than
Eddie human so what I've done is I've
taken some big celebrity chef dogs and I
want to just show them to you and maybe
you know some of them I don't know and
then you can tell me what you'd make for
him okay that's not like a good idea
okay first one we have David Chang's
survey oh I could not cook for David
Chang's dog I mean he's like the best
he's got to be the best fed dog I on the
planet I'd have to go with a doggie
beverage of some sort maybe a semifreddo
for him like a little light dessert
cuz he's probably had a very full dinner
from dad Tom Colicchio's Piper oh I love
Tom - these are gonna be really well-fed
dogs it looks like he's really into game
and I'm an upstate New Yorker and a lot
of my friends are really into venison so
I think I'd go with venison in kind of a
cidery juniper Brian Martha Stewart's
Zoe oh so in the spa oh that looks like
a toy right um I think I would make
something dainty like
chicken mut balls little meatballs for
puppies very mild a little grated carrot
Michael Symon's Ozzie Oh
Ozzy's a big boy you better come correct
your Rachel Ozzie needs um a juice
cleanse it looks like I think we're
we're busting out the Vitamix and some
kale for Oz Mike really what are you
feeding him mmm that's smoky and sweet
and a little bit fruity mm-hmm we're
still doing pretty okay this isn't so
horrible not yet not yet it'll get there
and this book and full thing I actually
think this is I'm setting a new cereal
er yeah they are you have such a great
welcoming disposition amazing
catchphrases I think that I come off a
little dispassionate Oh
so what I want to do is I want to show
you some notes some common complaints
from our commenters I just want to know
how are you as a TV that would handle
these sorts of issues okay
first off I should I be eating the wing
on camera I know that you go with the
spoon thing this time around but what
should I be doing no I just pulled a big
that's why I like the drumette so you
can get a big even bite when you're
looking to eat on camera you got to get
that bite down so you go back to talking
exactly when you have this part of the
wing it's too hard to negotiate around
the little balls so you got to kind of
stack your deck and eyeball where you're
going in for that bite and make it clean
and chew it up quick and get it get it
down can you give me a go to cooking Oh
face when the hot sauce hits me like
that before oh no your dude I would do
more like like slang see write it out
like a little sexier Oh or like a girl's
get you the wide eye but the boy should
be a lot like a cross-eyed like no no
way to have an out of my hair situation
that works for cartoons okay
all right the show with hot questions
and even hotter wings how's that as a
tagline we mailing it in I mean it
doesn't pop that hard
it doesn't yeah and it's too obvious
like you want something you know the
show with hotter questions and hotter
answer to show put hair on your chest
to show you know yeah yeah yeah like
visceral you want him to see a picture
but it's too literal to actually put the
word wings in it we always start off the
show with sriracha no big deal it's
rachis no big deal sriracha no big deal
t-shirt money yeah that's cool what
about this one this is from the Eric
Andre episode it's my personal favorite
and just goes Tinashe where you at to
not say where you where I like that and
that was a dramatic reading yeah as I
tried to do the impression I think I
look good and the impost hot ones oh you
need our names on the actual bottle at
every wow you cut your own sauce how you
roll
you're not the only one uh not the only
one like with Meghan Brianna you're not
the only one putting your hand in the
honey pots over here Rachel
hot ones kind of working too but I'm
curious what you think of this one
citrus bland kind of undercutting me I
love the citrus no I really love this
one my favorite so far I'm very
impressed with that
I would I would buy that as a consumer
beautiful Jesus really it's feels like
worth like 50 grand what you just said
I'm serious feel free to use it speaking
of catchphrases you have more than dj
khaled and some of your words we've
actually ended up in Webster's which is
certainly rare what abbreviation ended
up in the dictionary but that's
something you can put on your tombstone
well I hope I'm not gonna be there
anytime soon can you give me the
strangest origin story for one of those
yeah Mary started out yes when my mom
complements food her highest compliment
is that's disgusting her next highest
compliment is oh my god that's so good
so I'm on my show and there's nobody
there with me I'm cooking alone you know
18 years ago on Food Network and I go to
taste my food at the end of the show and
it was usually molten lava hot and
burning the whole inside of my mouth and
digester tract but I would have to say
something so I'd say YUM oh my god
that's good and I got some hate mail
because I was saying God oh really I'm
like I wasn't saying that about God I
was just saying God that foods good
people were writing letters but yeah so
controversial Rachel I got sent to the
principal's office and asked to refrain
from saying that
so I'd say YUM oh and then I'd have to
stop because I wasn't allowed to stay oh
my god so natural stop it just stopped
and then children started using it in
conjunction with my name they thought it
was like my last name children would see
me to book signing and save hmm how so
when we started our children's
initiative that became the name of the
initiative video right because the
little kids like to the yellow and I
sound like a cartoon to them I don't
think I've had this one this one profile
I'm just a guy that you're just you guys
okay fine mmm it does match your table
decoration beautifully I must say menu
when lemonade dropped in the Rachel Roy
rumors started a bunch of idiots on
Twitter thought that it was you Rachael
Ray not Rachel anymore I'm famous enough
to hang out with me wet hair is Becky
with the good hair but can you tell me
what it was like to be on the receiving
end of the beehives wrath the only time
I ever got mixed up with Rachel Rose
when I would get her dry cleaning and
occasionally her dinner reservation and
vice versa I'm nowhere near famous
enough to hang out and with the likes of
those folks the only reaction I had was
I guess it's cool just to be mentioned
in that world that people would think
that I was even hanging out yeah it's an
interesting Widow a moment I have five
jobs
I just don't pay attention to much other
stuff this one is now paying 100% here
help me know I got you it's stuck it
really is on there Annette yeah but you
know I played a little high school
football all right now you don't like
this one
taste-wise I don't like it's not your
favorite mm-hmm come on brother there
you go
oh that's real smoky right so smoky so
bitter woot yeah I have to say that's
not my favorite it's really thick too I
could not get it out of the bottle what
do you think with the heat it is really
hot but that's cuz it's got a lot of
seeds in it and chilies the heat comes
from the guts the ribs and the seeds are
what holds the heat for a chili pepper
to me that's not the most successful one
there's not enough balance and it's a
lot of smoking
yeah I know that you're a huge music fan
your husband isn't the cringe salt by
Southwest
all the time and be back in Chicago what
are some artists that are on your
kitchen playlist how do you think maybe
the be surprised to learn well right now
I'm obsessed with our close friends are
actually green hey and revolution radio
is phenomenal I've listened to a 12
times in the last like four days I'm
really obsessed with it it's hard to
find music we don't love when you get
the music a wonderful new the M&M box
set we love that you even got the M&M
box out of items a gift from friends of
ours is amazing
now I got the sweaty upper lip I got the
Nixon
any warnings about this one and you know
what you don't need a warning because
there's a radioactive bomb on it and it
says it's beyond insanity which kind of
acai does the math for you you know I've
had the office cold for like ten days
now this is doing so much better than
the design you tab and the claritin-d
and I didn't have to show my license
well right talk about smoke real real
food and Fuego so I want to talk about
two moments in your career and kind of
think of them as bookends oh I want to
take the FH I'm spread and then I want
to show the one with you and Michelle
Obama on the cover of your magazine
surrounded by vegetables and it's
starting to hit when I think about those
as sort of bookends I think that your
critics might think that those are more
divergent than they actually are first
well I didn't know what FHN was I
thought it was for home in whatever I'm
literally drooling well you got to get
me some tissues I thought it was really
cool for someone who's not a model and
at the time I was in my late 30s to take
their clothes off with and hang out with
a turkey in these ridiculous costumes
amazing I did it as a challenge I didn't
sleep the whole night before I was
trembling shaking but I'm proud of it
let's get real
thank you that's racial some literally
crying do you have to shoot after this
oh yeah then we're gonna definitely need
some more time for makeup
two left eye this next one
as mad doctoring 57 Rachel how you doing
Oh joking
I'll try let me see Becky Wead Rachel
battling battle shine I'm dizzy
whoa so not easy part of the interview
that is cinnamon in it that's weird kind
of a tasty sauce in my opinion kind of a
tasty sauce but I can't taste anything
right now
well could you just bad taste like
cinnamon I want to get your opinion on
this sort of 30-second just hand buzz
beautification of recipes awesome I wish
I had time to do more of them I just
think any any way you can express to
people how easy something is so that
they attack that thing that's a
successful marketing campaign
Rachel Mon let's do it
I can't get this one have you that's one
that's gonna be a jelly one two come on
I want to be a girl who could do all
number ten hi Rachel is loaded and we
gotta respect I'm gonna dab Oh
accidentally what no she's dead Rachel's
gone oh yeah I know Carl its inner a no
question there's this iconic drawing a
child picture of her choking doing them
why is she doing she's doing her job
there's a bunch of people helping her by
giving her plates and stuff it says I
got my picture oh yeah
so what I think is um hey holy [ __ ] babe
sweat a river runs through it so the
thing about these food shows is that
here a lot of times there are a lot of
tricks to make them look good I've done
them I know how it works yeah I read I
write on my shows they they prep it
sometimes they do is God be so mom
cooking it's gotta be something I'm
gonna let you off the hook Rachel
there's gotta be something good I like
it if it's a long cooking thing of
course there's a swab up it's a quick
cleaning thing that the show we just did
it's my food and I write all my meals
Holly gosh I did it through 30-second
plug is all yours this camera that
camera that camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life I
did all ten of these I'm Rachael Ray I
have five jobs this is thing I'm most
proud of I know I hear on my chest
I'm gonna go shave it before my next
show you roll when I kicked your ass cuz
I ate it all off a spoon
oh I got more than I did in Greenville